[Music]
how do I don't people know you guys have
known each other for a long time is my
voice still have an effect on it I am so
sorry guys okay okay we know live man
yes you can cut all this [ __ ] me and
Dave met and uh we all went to school
together we all want the Carbondale and
that's how we met I was doing the
hip-hop nights over there at the hangar
nine and I booked this guy once my my
first so ever wasn't was in Carbondale
hangar nine really yeah it wasn't my
show though I think it was pickles show
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah and then we
just became fast friends and we've been
friends ever since we tore it total
music together yeah yeah yeah and then
you didn't you wit when with Hannibal I
remember we used to go when we were
doing doing our thing and you're like
Dave like hey man like I got to go and I
was like hey t you know I feel him in
and I got you the ticket
you remember that time oh wait was that
in Minneapolis we were somewhere and I
was like yeah T you should do it man
where there's a last-minute gate it was
if something I know you know what it was
it was uh when you yeah when you got the
oddball tour I remember yeah and you're
like you know what Todd I'm gonna buy
your ticket I need you so do your thing
with the inflation and everything and so
now is the time where you should you
know I'll pay it back a little bit so
the interest yeah no that's great great
man you guys were going strong that's
great so they've used to me and Dave
used to tour all the time that was fun
we traveled the Czech Republic together
yeah that was crazy
that was good yeah before I started
touring with Hannibal I was torn with
Dave and we've
we've had some stories and some
adventures ya know it's the road life
man yeah yeah I got a good taste of it
before I got up with you is so I was uh
I was eased into it I wasn't just like
hey we're on the road now so yeah good
times
good time what cities did you just did
you just hit on this last round so it
was like about fourteen we did like you
started a Ferndale and then I found out
mister he played magic back I forgot the
name of the spot yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then I ended my part in a band organ do
you you've been to bend before haven't
been to been I've been to Eugene and
Portland yeah we didn't yeah we did
Portland I think and then we did Bend
and I went to LA after that and that was
then I came back here you know I've been
back so how was Bend Oregon
oh great man everybody's in such great
shape man like all these fancy stores
and stuff people there's sandals and
stuff it's like man it's like a very it
was just like holy smokes I need to
really start to exercise a little bit
more you know what I mean is it near
Eugene I don't even know it's a smaller
Airport yes man people with those foot
shoes and stuff like really Birkenstocks
know the toe Oh
workout shoes there's as little of a
shoe as it could be while still being a
shoe like the toes the 40 they talking
about the foot gloves yeah yeah I hate
those things
can you climb walls with those I don't
know what those are for what are they I
mean what do they say that they do
supreme strength strength under these so
I think so or it's like good it's good
for your I think it's good for your feet
when you run or some [ __ ] no but then I
also heard that it's that's all rumors
and they're actually terrible for your
hand yeah I like a nice barrier but hey
I'm doing the wrong things do you ever
do you record on the road at all like I
go places and do like an album in like a
spot for like two weeks
yeah go and just record there so I guess
that's considered on the road but not
like traveling no I mean like why you
dogs or maybe pop it you never know
I never really um which record the
latest project la and I looks like a
Jules like I do I have a final Kinney
album I did it in LA yeah that makes
sense right how many Kinney albums so
there's eight total but I just did the
final one and I feel good about like
Kenny's Harley on it it's all from his
wife's perspective oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
Jules Jules yeah yeah that's often Jules
perspective so I've been doing they have
a final record
[Music]
that's so that's the final chapter of
the center of the Dennehy Kenny Dennis
the final one yeah yeah I know more
Kenny Dennis I have a graphic novel that
I have with my guy
Owen okay yeah this China you know I
didn't really work so I just want to put
it yeah well then just say you were
gonna have like some kind of TV show I
didn't work out so you know I'm doing
this you know final find a final thing
and putting the kibosh and all yeah
that's what listeners sang Getti as a
character Kenny Dennis then he grabs as
his alter ego alter egos super Chicago
sports fan from what burb is he from
he's not from city like a lawyer I
thought yeah that's what I was really
going out for just this like this place
that was like an amalgamation of like
just everything that's mid-north yeah
not specifically but then yeah it got
deemed is Chicago how'd you come up with
uh him initially just will you goofing
around making an impression or somebody
in there you started you know like I was
like I I worked on the beer trucks
forever you know I and I and I delivered
beer like everywhere and I was like a
helper and then I like one time I you
know it really sad sack we've got to
wake up at 5:30 in the morning
yeah the doll she was in and then one
day it is very like a lonely isolated
thing and then I come back and I'm
watching like the Little League World
Series and they ask all the kids like
who's your favorite athlete who's your
favorite like what's your favorite movie
whatever and it just hit me like what if
somebody's favorite actor was
bryant-denny then like all of a sudden
the whole thing clicked from all my you
know I've delivered everywhere so the oh
I got it is
favorite drink all those bears Fox socks
most favorite day Sunday favorite team
the Bears favorites or ventures stairs
fast favors so Panza also the newest
weatherman still in the music the Bulls
favorite actor dead a favorite Rico
those bears ox ox boss boss boss
oh it's kitty Dennis his wife's name is
Jose his buddy's name is Curtis and so
on and so forth and his I it was like a
magic thing like seeing it all for my
eyes like oh yeah
ding ding ding ding the bloodsport you
know like Tanaka she'd though she could
knock a trade me
[Music]
like really delved into the car man it
was a magical thing because I I just I
just saw it man like holy cannoli yeah
cuz I remember when you were developing
the character you wait you were either
working for ups or you imagined them
working for ups and you just kept you
kept going
welcome Bravo for you put you on the
workers true blue collar yeah it was
just like yo this guy is our friends
like people call Kenny you know like in
the party's not happening you call
Kenny's got it yeah Curtis to get your
toilets fixed and and are you did Curtis
I don't know if you remember on that
there was like uh it was a 7-inch that
came out yeah and you so Curtis is the
the plumber right his plumber I don't
know he's just his best friend who we
used to be on the job and now he jobs
that taxicab the airport things are
trying to save up for a snail sanctuary
[Laughter]
yeah it's a problem but he's good but
you better some of the songs you you
specifically say he's good with toilets
lawless used to got a job yeah I mean
he's a real fellow I mean what fella
doesn't know toilets I don't know toilet
that's I'm saying that you see the what
I'm trying to say I can make my own
chandeliers guy yeah you know they're
all like artsy look at this movie take a
look at this RT I'm talking about a real
thing like a damn table this is gonna be
the last of the what the character last
part of it so yeah there's this one but
then I did another Grimm Grimm teachers
album and Grimm is like when Kenny first
did that whole Dennehy it always bugged
me like why can the guy rat than me and
Fidel put him in this Grimm teachers
group that came out in the early 90s
yeah to explain him like that's his
backstory well you know that's why he
can rap because in my mind this guy like
how could he just closely you were
trying to justify it bug me like why I
can just do just hop on a mic and do
favor dr. 30 favorite you know like Oh
Grimm teachers so then they broke up the
whole Shack thing and then but there's a
follow-up album before they broke up
called the end is near
[Music]
[Music]
it's a lot of material I've heard some
of it
I'm that all the way yeah yeah with the
ark yeah I know I'm caught up with you
know parts yeah west of Western a
highlight for me I remember putting it
on in an uber yeah in LA and then the
guy just started speeding and we won and
we weren't on a straightaway raloo icon
Laurel Canyon is somewhere sourwine D so
he was driving it was long Canyon at
night no and this dude was just get
pumped up by Western Western it's a
driving baseline you know that the whole
thing started in LA like trying to order
a pizza from Chicago and you're in LA
yeah and you said yeah average is 2 to 3
37 uh like like the the casted or drive
and like Oh solo how do you get there
you're like oh take western well you're
gonna turn right over happens in take
they take western and go about 22,000
blocks west that's about like 4,000
miles yeah okay cool Oh like four days
and and the guy comes and drops it off
and he says thank you and you give Mike
a five hour tip oh thanks
that's pretty funny I thought 12 mm
black semester good idea you know past
the first Avenue go through go through
Iowa just don't stop so they had nothing
to do with Fela being on like say say
adderall or something like that
like he's nah he just got high because I
was playing other stuff and he was a
fiber to it he was like chillin and then
west of Westar came on yeah he when he
was a what his dad he asked me what it
is what is that uh-huh said Serengeti
man yeah fast beat I played it my DJ
says sometimes mm-hm
sometimes I start yeah obvious I was
like weird cuz it doesn't really fit
into a if you truck if you're playing
the club be Club stuff that we be
playing yeah yeah but sometimes I say
hey guys
we bought the veer off the beaten path a
little bit yeah everybody just go get a
drink and we buy the chill
I'm about to play some some get him
about to play some Cavanaugh yeah in
here did you record with Mike over Mike
eagle on the in the studio de child
send tracks each other no no we do all
our together like that's my fingers I
just I need to be there yeah you know
what I'm saying so yeah yeah we could at
all make about three three days man oh
wow that was really really cool I lost
Matt a mass space beauty display box
case ivory piece named Susan tropical
and transparent
movie courtroom drama in a coming-of-age
movie treat the ladies well warm chest
and a fuzzy I know we just met just
muffle like a hammock net cheese baby
wet get your total neck is cold like
rain check or being outdated technology
monkeys I'm busy painting recorded at
mic spot yeah just you know covert yeah
awesome yeah me and get either that you
me album like in a week
[Music]
she berated muta for the dinner good
what's the what's the you guys got the
Sisyphus right yes so it's used Sufjan
Stevens and Sun Lux so you guys have one
album out together right
or does it do it to like the first ones
called SSS yeah yeah yeah and then the
second ones out to right
[Music]
tell me how you feel
[Music]
[Music]
people who listen to this gonna have to
catch up on some [ __ ] man yes 20 albums
what geez that's sort of embarrassing
huh si si si that's my problem
like I would just like I never had like
booking so I just do an album release it
but I'm not really working the release
you're not horn in right cuz like I'm
not gonna call and like set up my own
stuff like hey this is you know what I'm
saying yeah so in lieu of that just keep
on doing stuff but then with like the
Cavanagh and the yoni and gety thing it
was really dope because we just did the
record and then we toured it yeah they
were like this is how we do business
right actually this is how you run a
music man yeah so that felt good do it
tour make the bread inin oh you're
extremely prolific you get a lot done
yeah well what's your like it was it was
interesting hearing that that no we say
that you just needed like how much of a
writer with you are you dad to justify
his ability to rap by creating a fake
rap so what's your approach to writing
the songs where do you you know have you
know just a few lines written down or
you do you you know freestyle part of it
and then take that and but when you
coming up when you record for like the
kidney stuff that I get like each
project I'll have like an arc just in my
head you know I'll get just by just
sleep on it and you get starts to just
fill it out yeah I've known I'm saying
so so that's how old Kenny stuff the
other stuff used to be just me trying to
sort out my own things
we try to write my way through my life
been along here time does slap on my
last sided love my pumpkin pie girl
passed me another cup of my tie it just
needs ice it just needs ice birthday
parties those weren't even girls hotel
rooms with a woman named Marilee plastic
pearls on my wrist get in my six get in
my six the Cadis three there was like an
arc of like me endures because there's
did some records with that and there's
home from workaholics right so on this
third one it was like this group that
they were touring called perfecto yeah
and you never really heard the music of
perfecto and I was like ah so we had to
do that actual music so we did it's all
like that I don't know my brothers and
sisters the mrs. amidst to some future
here the plan team she walked
different scene so so you hear about it
on the third Kenny dentist but you just
hear of it yeah then we did an actual
album four songs then on the b-side is
how the / the producer got into evolved
into the into the fray right I enjoyed
the perfecto it was very nostalgic for
me okay
I felt like old b96 music are you I
didn't see one snapchat from you about
the perfecto either listen a you're not
even on snap it's all one barely on
Twitter why one thing you know I don't I
don't care what they say about you you
are okay in my book I haven't seen it so
I'd the final Jules Becker right dog and
and my my thing is I want to do instead
of a release show do a three City
softball game that that's like a 16-inch
softball in LA New York and Chicago so
you come to the game and you play and
then that's the release show and it's
playing the music there I don't even
know you just just just just come in and
just play the game like a 16-inch
softball like yeah be doping like LA you
know this guy takes his a softball
serious he's always are you in a league
yeah I'm gonna leave guy I play this
media league here every Monday it's
really fun
yeah are you what's your stats what's
your output oh I pitch you pitch pitch
underhand yes that's to go out like six
to 18 feet art something like that
well yeah I bet hit so I'd like to do
the the thing Kenny Dennis first annual
softball game slash jewels release party
then that same night do a show and then
sponsored by Hannibal Burres sure Oh
play softball with the guy's wife make
curly fries you saw baby driving what'd
you think yeah I mean everybody loves it
it's rated very high I said what do you
think
[Laughter]
you know what do you think not everybody
I might have one in there with a bad
mood but I realize that because
everybody loves it me I like Jon Hamm
you know in the flick I thought it was
fun yeah yeah I you know like I've seen
a lot of flicks lately one thing that
you need to know about Getty is he
watches every movie in in the theater
like I had no idea that you were in
Baywatch
you didn't pay what I talked about
thoroughly enjoyed it yeah I did man
knows it was cool
have you done any acting or have been
approached to audition or have any
ambitions to do yeah I mean sure but
it's just as much as the thing yet that
you can't just hop in you know what I'm
saying you have to actually go and do
auditions and stuff I did one little
indie flick I think and I got an email
to do something but yeah I mean seems
great
but I don't know if I could do do the
the headshots and actually move to LA
and do all that because it's not
headshots anymore people aren't and all
I see on the internet just an tickle
yeah so yeah yeah I love it
well do a photo shoot shoot in the base
me like oh and the JIT friend he was uh
he's a paint here's a painter he had a
key put up a Craigslist ad and he well
he's an artist I got like a literal
artist painter and then he was trying to
give because he's just starving artists
and he needed a paint you needed the
paint to survive and so he put up a
Craigslist as hey does anybody need any
painting work and some old like creepy
guy hired him and he had him like paint
use like he was weird he had me like
painting all weird like random stuff
like hey paint this lampshade but as as
he was doing it he kept saying creepy
things like go ahead take off your shirt
like the same exact yeah like oh yeah
just loosen up your belt you know take
out God take off your hand like you know
what this this belt is a little tight
the next thing you know Crazy's been
there for weeks beautiful water
beautiful spritzers yeah lemonade some
creepy people out there why not and why
not do you guys play the Lollapalooza no
no no I don't play a lot of Palooza
they don't do they don't do comedy there
and they don't respect my theremin work
hey Lollapalooza his Hannibal Burres you
didn't book me this year but listen to
this [ __ ] it's my Lollapalooza this
Lollapalooza how much would that charge
for that set you hunted racks yeah you
get you played any vessels this summer
I've ever played a festival really yeah
we did that weird ass wanted cut no or
no no yeah we that was an offense no we
did the the Logan swear Arts Festival
before I think No thank you no that was
a festival cutting the horror remember
uh a Casio Tom was doing that to him oh
yeah that was fun yeah yeah yeah that
was weird ass I like that I enjoyed that
that was a weird as gig yes so weird
just the ran cut Nora is like what east
of that's where now you ever see
pictures of that that that church made
out of human bones no no there's a
there's a church it's called coach Denis
Kostin ishka and it's a it's a church
made out of human bones and it's a
little town it looks like a like
Transylvania it looks like we're like
vampires live and we had a random gig
there we didn't know it was we didn't
know it was a festival but we walked up
and yeah it was a it was a full-on
festival and it was a good time yeah
Jacob whatever I forgot his last name
but this that's still going on it's like
I think about that sometimes I was good
remember when Owen was playing and the
Sun was setting he was doing the that
that that song was of you
from a fire fire a good natural love
yeah that's what I was calling natural I
thought that was amazing the Sun was
said you should have been there Hannibal
I wish I was yeah yeah yeah I wish I was
there
[Music]
do you have any plans to go to Europe
because you did I believe Berlin and in
London or something like that
I didn't yeah no bird I didn't do Berlin
the UK and Australia yeah
UK Ireland Scotland England having done
Berlin I'd like to I heard it they have
some fantastic nightlife out there yeah
it's good have you toward Berlin yeah
yeah they have this yeah mm-hmm you've
been to Berlin so many times
oh did you like what I was gonna say was
did you go to a Berlin sex party but you
don't want to tell us well what will
they have won and it takes place for
like maybe 72 hours and uh or maybe even
more and it's like a studio 54 thing
where you have to be permitted in yeah
I'm saying
so are you yes are you being for real
right now I'm serious you know be like
wait so it's a 70 is 72 hours of just a
lot of people banging each other yeah I
don't think I do well at a sex party
it's too much distraction too much
pressure
yeah just watch especially like and
almost pictures like hey hey man I saw
Hannibal Burres away bump it away just a
quick like it's a [ __ ] whatever look at
him man man his eyes are closed he's
just like it's so much passion it is a
dude like I stand behind it they close
in like light like on that joke but
instead like the dude behind oh yeah but
it made for some good gifts gifs
yeah gifs or gifts yes I think it's
awesome any gifts or gifs gifts yes yes
yes
get know how many kids you got man me
speaking of gifts
[Laughter]
you're not talk about that
illegally what you got going on
yeah no no no it's all fine so I heard
that you have a little one aníbal uh
well that's not what I like to call my
penis but all right now I don't have any
kids you might have a couple in
Australia that you don't know about let
me know that's one thing you know they
didn't let you know immediately you know
this ain't the 70s in the 70s cats were
out here just banging and disappeared
you just can't do that you can't do that
you just bang you leave it in and you
get in your car and you just had a kid
somewhere you have to hear about it she
didn't have your phone number and then
like not that I will say I want to do
that but it seems like a lot of cats I
never met my father
yeah just drove away why now you could
just just just look at him on like he's
still posting yep dad you know yeah he's
on Instagram he's taking pictures with
Legos and stuff where's your dad
might just be boring and that's like you
know it may be in the 70s if you never
met a father
you kind of mythologize in a bit oh he's
probably you know he's a Rolling Stone
he could be your NFL player who knows he
might be in a band right
now you deny my dad playing call of duty
yeah snapchatting all the time why won't
he spend time with me yes y'all the
[ __ ] man bball I thought you were
doing that wait hold on hey wait so
Hannibal you yeah speaking of JZ young
and you and your property you must have
a solid credit score maybe eight ten
actually oh sorry yeah I have terrible
credit somehow yeah it's really bad bad
isn't like 7:01 or bad is in like 550
I'll tell you cuz I get updates on it my
credit score is isn't that good but but
but you wanna you own a unit and you
also on a vehicle and you own a house in
slope it's called cash I just did it all
with cash no I don't know the vehicle
here's my credit score look at this
there's no mortgage show me the cash I
don't even know what it look at that
here it is right I got Credit Karma
yeah score category poor but what's the
actual score it says payment history a
hundred percent every weird my credit
score in it and you know what
doesn't matter where you got cash he
used to use the bottom you got to get
catch that [ __ ] used to bother me but
now and now I you know what that I don't
know if it was last year or two years
ago I was in San Diego and like a Macy's
or some [ __ ] and and they were you want
to get amazes car tonight and I've been
rejecting them for years and then this
particular day I don't know why I said
[ __ ] it I want to try and then and then
uh I got rejected for a Macy's card 2015
but weren't you but you had like a
Macy's commercial
so wait here's uh who you talk with on
this one there's this past run you just
finished up as me and a fella named
Chesky Ramos yeah and you got a guitar
sound like you got yeah so you know
Chesky then these great guys think
Chiefs may yeah we did a nice fine yeah
you know it was a nice time and like
just when I'm starting to get down on
myself like singer little tunes yeah
traveling and tunes I say why not you
just can't start doing that comparison
[ __ ] yeah I'm saying just take it for
what it is have some fun hey why not
hey hey hey hey why not well we all die
one day you know sit around now having
fun yeah yeah you still gonna die yeah
but I'm not so I better have fun hey hey
well we used to talk we'd have a blast
you have a blast yeah blast you had a
blast in that bus we're going around the
bus waking up in a new city every day we
had a blast
what new restaurant are we gonna try an
a you know what today I'm not gonna
drink any juice
those were good times me I was fun yeah
I'd like to do that again sometime yeah
you know back to Eastern Europe Eastern
yeah here we come [ __ ] with Lunchables
yes yeah I buy that [ __ ] all the time on
the road like I know it's not the best
for you but it feels better than like
getting some stuff like a McDonald's
something yeah these do you enjoy
lunchable I haven't had any why would I
miss that weird just weirdly little sick
processed ham yeah why not little
sandwiches
I like Lunchables I'll still hit him as
a grown man I mean they they're like
they're like they charge like three
dollars or something like that go to a
gas station get a Lunchables and a naked
juice naked juice why not you know not
to go back to interview you but in
Baywatch you look spell you look real
like like like you've been working out
but was that the case no Baywatch look
like you ain't put me in a terrible
shirt I was in I was on fat guy mode and
Baywatch very various but you still for
the most part when you're about to fill
me I notice that you do you'll do your
little cleanses and you'll do your you
do your no drinking thing and get
prepared two shots of you your healthy
guy I mean I want to be I think about it
does it does that count yes
you know I well no but I think about it
a lot too right you know you know like I
thought about a job you know I'm saying
I I want to do more do some biking and I
always think one day you'd get it all
together you start exercising you just
stop and then you start to feel bad
after you stop cuz you do when you first
get that workout in and you haven't done
one in a while yet oh yeah this feels
good my brain I feel clear right get the
endorphins you got the endorphins you
get the ideas flowing start flowing yeah
but then you just you gotta dedicate the
at least 30 read as a day yeah I
remember you used to you used to walk to
work every morning at sudden at sunrise
historic at the shaman shop that was a
good time I enjoyed that man like a nice
you get a job where you have to walk
like two miles there in fact yeah that's
that's a little bit of exercise that's
that's that's a good routine every day
you have to walk that's why I kind of
like having a dog cuz you have to force
yourself to take it for a walk why not
but I just I I feel weird with poop
being involved you know it's all picking
up the [ __ ] the [ __ ] part yeah nobody
likes I just rather take a walk without
maggots you were
these these shoes these giant slats on
them and you just push it in the grass
with the with the shoes instead of
picking it up
you know what they need yeah you know
they just smoosh it in like what are you
talking about what that me used to be
like a little pill is your dog [ __ ] you
throw that pill on there no you're like
those little puppets those puppets that
you throw on the ground and they pop
yeah something like that but for dog
poop but you just throw it on a dog poop
and it saturates it disappears
you ain't gotta touch it or it explodes
the pool and then evenly distributes it
in the fertilizer yeah Tony what is that
this is uh are you doing a plug right
now illiquid illiquid
Tony can plug it outside sponsors I got
this in liquid here Tony doing side
deals out in this [ __ ] I
respected those I get upset when I
watching UFC and they have some weak-ass
walkout music mm-hmm they be walking out
to some [ __ ] sometimes yeah this
will get you have to fight yeah they
have Rolla vein guess you have to fight
no disrespect but yeah they have like
things where they can't it seems like
they can't really do certain things
seems like they can pick their songs man
oh yeah they pick some way yeah somebody
walked out to Chubby Checker do the
twist I was at that [ __ ] it was like
what are you can't believe that man they
don't like the like fella had a choice
between like four songs and and that's
the one that he recognized maybe I think
sometime I don't know they'd be walking
out the ballots and [ __ ] sometimes you
just ballad and just mouthing that's
just singing that [ __ ] yeah I mean
watching it you don't look cool right
now maybe that's not what you're going
for and
forever what would you walk out to mob
be mob I'm deep which one shook ones
from the cradle to the grave
oh okay that's good yeah forever from
the cradle to the grave
kid watch your back one time coming no
way they lock me up for 12 days I can't
comprehend now I'm a free man on the
streets again so Joe Bob the prodigy is
one of your favorites too huh alright P
by the way yeah all right Pete project
yes sir
terrible the terrible loss Kalista a lot
of prodigy lately listen to that yeah
yeah you know it says I had title I
wasn't using it as much into this album
I just had a said one of those things
which I as somebody that's kind of
frugal I hate when I subscribe to
something and then forget I subscribe to
some foreclosure website and I just
gotta keep on all gotta unsubscribe to
that and I see it on my statement $40.00
a god a month and I don't even use it
the jay-z album forced me not forcement
but then I started using title more I
don't have some great playlists on just
a playlist I don't want to just keep on
picking songs and going to nah that's
too much pressure you know then I'll
just pick the playlist sat down oh good
fourth of July conversation yeah DJ that
ticket that I got you that one time it
was first class to dude
ya know was it wasn't me say thank you
oh [ __ ] you wanna say thank you didn't
say thank you thank you
he just left I woke up in the morning it
felt so lonely in that room because we
just share the same rooms yeah yeah and
then I woke up this guy's this guy's
ritual is always hilarious cuz every
time
get in the room first thing you would do
is strip down those underwear and hop
under the sheets yeah it'll be like
three and a half turn Oney Billa okay
time the rest come on team come on have
you noticed an important time the rest
I'm the rest wait 15 minutes like gosh
one time we were like late we were like
running late we had to we had to go to
us another city and the drive was long
but we had to like I don't know what was
going through your head but you're like
okay okay okay okay and then you started
drawing the bath what you're feeling the
tub with water you're like okay okay
I'll be right there I'm just gonna take
a quick bath will you ever in in a gang
and follow question when was your last
existential crisis I know I wasn't in
the game were you in a game yeah yeah I
was I knew people that were in gangs
yeah so they would sometimes do the
handshake with me and I was enough I we
we stroll around and we speeches know
all the game the gang handshakes yeah it
was cool yeah it felt good
yeah yeah but but like some of my guys
would actually go do it with people and
I'm like man dude you're really fun
right now man you know that's not you
but the exits what does that mean
I don't know in existential crisis a
crisis what does it mean do you ever say
what why am I doing this what does this
mean what is life about oh yeah I mean
all the time I mean well five minutes
ago yeah I mean I just want to have a
good time good that's a good hot dog
right there yeah why not
softball in the mall ball just enjoy
myself
yeah you just sink thinking of that
stuff all the time
stop thinking on the road oh geez deep
was a the worst time I was in Berlin I
was about to go on tour
but I was doing an album in Berlin the
last record I did with sicker man and it
was during the wall festival so Berlin
was like jam-packed crowded so and it
was just me in this room so we would
record but he would finish at 7:00 then
drop me off of this hotel so I'm missing
his hotel just by myself and the streets
are crowded and I didn't want to like
Vinci you know I don't want to hang like
by myself and yeah then that's not
nothing
that's not a good time what I'm gonna do
I go go go check out this old church by
myself yeah so anyway like man I was
just freaking out and I couldn't sleep
cuz my the jetlag and I'm on like the
fifth floor which is actually the sixth
floor is this license starts at zero or
whatever and the window is open out and
what really [ __ ] me up is my Netflix
didn't work because I had all these
shows I was watching to calm me down
yeah and then I get there it's like this
isn't for your viewing area I just threw
everything off and I couldn't sleep
enough staying up until I till breakfast
times like a week it was a sight so that
was a crisis I guess that was or just
foolish person that's an existential
cause was terrible the window should not
and that's what I realized windows
should not open out like you know you
know like you know the the like hotels
are like lonely places where people die
yeah you know is it true that's why they
should only open this I get it now these
things open up let's take a good with a
burly I mean wider than you can no
window ever open like dividend oh yeah
so you could just literally just jump it
that's it this is that's it for me I
don't know if that's a diet I mean I
guess it depends on what type of six
floors that is yeah sixth floor might
just be goddamn no this is those those
six floors out yeah man you know I'm
saying and the concrete's a lot harder
it seems like I'm saying there's like
real old concrete's I've been there for
like just thirteen hundreds oh yeah we
got like
they remember the first time we went
there they had lost my luggage and all
and I have my still in my travel clothes
so it was basically like sweats
converses they didn't have Mike they
didn't bring so I didn't have my winter
clothes nothing and it was in the middle
of the winter remember it was like the
tundra out there it's freezing
everything's covered in ice this is in
Berlin yeah yeah they didn't they don't
salt the streets yeah I was just falling
everywhere
laughing right so silly how could they
live like that socha no sand no ice
nothing it's just like ice ice
that's it they must have been switching
mayor's I don't think this one will come
out either so it'll be 45 out of 48
[Music]
[Music]
and don't forget about the first annual
Kenny Dennis jewel jewels album release
softball extravaganza sponsored by
Hannibal Burres and maven music where do
we find you okay so I'm selling the
double album LP jewels for $55
there's only 15 left 15 Serengeti wraps
sir erupts at Big Cartel dot-com 15 left
and Counting 15 left don't sleep don't
see anything like that pardon for a date
sir he got it stuff like that coming up
anyway any shows I got nothing
I actually might take a job a jo-jo
would that be something what can Brown
do for you put you on the workers crew
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]